and it's believed so well done good
okay we are live so for everybody
watching uh i'm doing
a one-on-one interview with uh dan
pontefract he's launching a new book
are we allowed to say the title of the
book we can call the working title evan
i mean go for it
okay so the book is he wrote to me said
i'm writing a new book it's called let
me see it's work not jail
the difference between a job and a
career with purpose and he wanted to
interview me for the book and i said hey
let's turn this into a google hangout
so everybody can benefit from the
knowledge and uh and we can give dan a
little promotion too so
then welcome aboard uh maybe just a
quick intro for everybody watching and
then and then ask away
excellent well i appreciate your time
and i've been looking forward to this
all week
short week but looking forward to it
nonetheless uh
who am i well my last name means broken
bridge in latin so i like to say evan
i'm the antithesis
of my last name i like to build bridges
nice so i've been kind of an academic
in the professional ranks and uh
currently chief envisioner at telus
which is a fancy way to say
we're here to help other organizations
transform their culture
transform their organizations and with
my kind of academic education experience
and this sort of last 12 years in the
corporate ranks
i really have been noodling and thus now
been writing a lot over the last five or
six years about
organizations and people
the first book that came out about a
year and a half ago now
flat army creating a connected and
engaged organization
was the investigation of what's wrong
with essentially
leadership and what might we do from an
organizational leadership perspective to
get people
feeling better inside the organization
that they're not just part of the
proletariat
that in fact you know they can be part
of a solution they can be included
you know in ideas and
answers and customer facing solutions
that's i think one of the problems with
organizations today it's just so
wretched from a command and control
industrial revolution perspective
that we needed a new organizing culture
now
to me there's a yin yang to what is
every coin right so the one side of the
coin is what's wrong with leadership and
what should our organizations do
this next book which i'm really
intrigued to ask you a few questions
about
is the flip side what's wrong with us
meaning the employees in the
organization i think have a
culpability to sort of that level of
disengagement in the organization i
think they need to take some ownership
and ultimately to uh induce some
gumption into their own
working lives so i'm curious from your
perspective my first question if you
don't mind
yeah yeah good do you in your experience
have you noticed the difference between
people and their mindsets in a job
in a career and those that really are
flourishing like it seems that you meet
these people sometimes and they were
destined to do what they do
and they don't think about it as a job
or a career and i'm wondering if
if you had definitions on or thoughts on
the difference between those types of
titles
we're getting deep right from the start
that wow he just hit me hard um
you know what i think a lot of people
get up every day
in the morning and they drive to a job
that they hate
yeah i mean i deal most with
entrepreneurs i don't deal so much with
the corporate side but
i deal with a lot of people who are in
companies who
who who hate their job there and
i mean it's their own fault for being in
this position but also
the companies for not necessarily
recognizing the talent or using them
properly or
or standing for something important and
i think a lot of people
um i mean i don't know exactly the
direction you want to take with the book
if it's like a
guidance for uh for companies and what
to do but
a lot of people are
a lot of people have a dream for what
they want to do you know like we have a
dream
we wish we could do this i i always
dreamed i could be a bowler but instead
i'm stuck doing you know pr
for whatever company and and we're
afraid to chase our dreams
and a lot of times that dreams could
could work within a company
but there's so much you know as you go
down a path
you get traction there and you get
experience there
and society tells you to keep going
because that's where the money is
it's harder to switch paths especially
as you get older right it's harder to
switch past and do something else
that you feel you love and we get stuck
on this path and we get
uh we have you know dependents and
family and
people we have to look after and then it
becomes really of these
chains of habit that hold you back and
be able to go after what you really
want to do so interestingly then uh you
touched on a couple pieces there so one
i wanted to really poke your brain
um viscerally in the forehead there is
entrepreneurial there are entrepreneurs
and entrepreneurialism sorry
so in in sort of your experience
what distinguishes the entrepreneur
who's successful and thus
really knocking it out of the park
versus those that are
a hazard to use the term but wannabes
and they they're sort of
they're trying hard but there's
something missing are there key traits
behaviors you know
attributes that you see for the
successful entrepreneur
and why he or she is loving what they do
versus those that
aren't quite frankly yeah there are
there are two main things
um that i've seen and i've done tons of
research modeling famous entrepreneurs
and how they got started and
there's no one common trait in terms of
personality trait a lot of people think
hey i have to be outgoing i have to be
well spoken i have to you know the
education side of things i have to have
a you know
high school education university
education you don't have to be the type
a personality you don't have to be a
nice person
to be a good entrepreneur right like
there's all these we may look at
those people who are making waves like
richard branson and oprah winfrey and
the high profile people but there's a
ton of successful entrepreneurs
who are not high profile who hate who
are not people people
you know hate the limelight and just sit
down and do their thing what makes a
difference
most important things one is that you
love what you're doing
and too many people that i see
want to be entrepreneurs because they
want they're chasing a lifestyle they
want to you know make their
make their own decisions be their own
boss they want to leave the corporate
ladder
they see opportunities to make money but
they're not doing it because they
have this burning desire to do it
they're doing it because they're just
trying to make money and escape
this life that they don't want it's so
so so important that you love what
you're doing and you look at most
entrepreneurs the guys who have made it
you look at any famous success story it
wasn't easy
they failed for years and years and
years and years uh
you know one of my favorite stories is
george lucas who's from lucasfilm star
wars indiana jones
he went to film school at a time where
nobody who went to film school
ever got a job i mean his whole family
thought it was crazy were you going to
film school
you know everybody thought it'd just be
a ticket taker at disney
and his first six years in business were
total failure
total absolute failure no commercial
success
at all he thought about quitting and
going to get a job like not only his
friends and family saying george you're
nuts
but he thought regularly about what like
what am i doing why am i
sticking with this thing yeah and
eventually when he made star wars he
thought it was too wacky for the general
public
he thought people wouldn't embrace it
that was too crazy too out there and
star wars became this huge hit for him
he's now worth you know four or five
billion dollars whatever it is
but like do you have the passion to
stick with something through six years
of failure
before it becomes successful most people
don't they quit
because you have to be a little bit you
have to love what you do so much that
you would do it anyway you're doing it
to do it
and if you do it long enough you find a
way to turn it into a business where
most people they don't have that
they don't have that passion enough and
as soon as it gets hard
you're doing something just to make
money you join a network marketing
company because you're promised
you know big riches in three months if
you do these 10 steps
get rich quick guide on whatever you
those things never work
it always takes longer than you think
it's gonna take uh so that's the first
part is like
the guys who become highly successful
are passionate they love what they're
doing they keep going through all
hurdles and the second part is they got
started
yeah like they actually got started
and that's the big thing that a lot of
people don't do if they're working at a
company they hate their job and they
hate their life and they have this
vision
do something about it like you gotta
take some action
you are accountable for your life the
cavalry is not coming to save you
you have to go take action and do
something it doesn't have to mean you
quit your job and you go full time and
you
you burn all your bridges right yeah
nice
but you'd like do something small part
time like you take steps towards living
the life that you want and sometimes
that's a business and sometimes that's
switching careers or going to a new
company it doesn't have to be
like as much as i force you know i love
entrepreneurship that's my default
thinking but
for a lot of people they don't want to
be entrepreneurs and that's cool too
yeah yeah so um does capitalism
play a part and that's a detriment to
the success or unsuccess of people i you
mentioned
a couple times don't do it for the money
do it for your passion for your love do
because
that's what and who you are put on this
earth for
but does keeping up with the joneses and
the illusion of money the
um you know capitalism in and of itself
creates some of that angst and some of
that uh
misconception and the perception that
that's who you're supposed to be
uh i you know i haven't thought that
deeply about it i don't know if it's
capitalism i don't know if it's a
culture thing we learned
growing up to get a job
right we go to school you're expected to
go get a job
you don't learn a lot about becoming an
entrepreneur
in most classes you know i didn't i
didn't learn about it when i went
through university there wasn't
classes on entrepreneurship
there isn't enough of uh if we're
talking about curriculum
and education and you know societal
views there's not enough about
following your passion like where do you
learn to follow your passion
where you learn that from where you
learn to take risk and
like our society will often i think at
least in north america there may be a
little more tolerance towards doing your
own thing in individualism than in other
countries where
you're expected to take over you know
the family business or you're expected
to become
a certain profession because that's how
it's been for generations so other
cultures might have a harder time than
than here in north america but still
like where do you learn how to
where do you learn how to find your
passion where do you learn what you're
excited about
and what kind of opportunities that may
lead you towards you know
i became an entrepreneur when i met two
uh people in university and they had a
business
and asked me to join as a struggling
business i became a partner in it
up until then when i graduated high
school you look at my high school
yearbook it says i
where are you in 20 years you know the
classic question i wrote uh vp at a
major investment bank
yeah you know like that was my that was
my dream job and if i didn't meet those
two entrepreneurs in university
my life would be totally different i
turned down opportunities with merrill
lynch
and mckinsey consulting at a university
to
do my own thing with a struggling
business that wasn't working because
somehow it just felt right
in high school and into university is
was that sort of your mindset
i'm going to make money as an investment
hedge fund manager director vp
and then you're like wait a second there
are other ways that
i'm programmed and by meeting these
uh cohorts you're like oh this is a
different way in which i can
live my life and was that a trigger
because of where you were before
uh i don't think necessarily money was
the number one
like i'm gonna go become an investment
banker because i can make a lot of money
i did in i was interested like i like
stocks i liked
you know i took finance courses i liked
economics i
i that so it was just kind of like a
natural progression for me i knew i
hated sciences i dropped those as soon
as i could
uh you know so i just moved towards this
because
i enjoyed it but but entrepreneurship as
a path
and and having skills or tool sets or
teachers to help guide you on finding
your passion that i didn't have that i
mean i went to private school too
i'm scared what happens in the public
school system um
yeah we don't have enough of it i mean i
didn't have role models i didn't have
people in my family who are
entrepreneurs i didn't have
even distant family or entrepreneurs i
didn't grow up around entrepreneurs so
it wasn't
wasn't in my psyche i think a lot of
entrepreneurs come
they may come from entrepreneurial
families they have to learn it somewhere
yeah they've been inspired somewhere a
book a movie family you're
you know somewhere you have to get
inspired by it um
but it's like you look at the top guys
look at the guys who've really made it
they're doing it not they're not doing
it for the money you know
you look at steve jobs steve jobs was
a multi-millionaire in his 20s yeah
millionaire in his 20s and he kept
working until
until he died trying to make something
great happen you know his incentive was
to put a dent in the universe
you know how many people keep working
when you have tens of millions of
dollars before you're 30.
and strangely enough
under his leadership apple became the
most valuable company in the world by
market cap
even though his personal goal was never
on the money sure it's important like
you got to make money you got to make
money to
eat you know live all that your business
has to make money for shareholders but
it was never
his number one goal and yet he built the
most viable company in the world
where do you learn that yeah well
so then it would be an interesting segue
to ask you about sort of business
schools
and what's going on there like are we
just pumping out
in mbas and b-coms and just universities
and colleges in general
more of what has been sort of
exacerbating the point that
it's it's money and economics that
should be your passion
not real passion like is there something
that you
found in today's graduates or
yesterday's graduates that's the same
um so i mean i think in my experience
i'm not so far removed
i'm i'm how old am i i'm 33 i'm 34 in
may so i'm not so far removed from
uh i had a undergrad degree bachelor of
commerce and finance from university of
toronto
uh i think what it does well is give you
the technical tools to perform at a job
so a lot of people out of rotman where i
went to went on to become
accountants i went on to become bankers
and
these are the people in my graduating
class and the the
the skills you learn the stats the
economics all of those
skills you need to use when you go out
and get a job in that
the tougher questions like what if
that's not even for you like for me i
was running my business
while i was at university and
i discovered that this wasn't what i
wanted so i'm in this program that
doesn't support me
um so i you know i don't know i think
it's more
like how can we get because that's great
for a lot of students
you know that experience is great they
learn skills it's great they go get
internships that's great
for people who really want that path
it's just how do you help there's so
much
uh uncertainty and angst and pressure
on young people coming out of high
school and university to
pick one thing that they're going to do
for the rest of their life and focus on
that
and that like we don't give them the
tools to pick that thing how do you know
what
what you're supposed to do how do you
get exposure to entrepreneurship or
other
interests that might help you along your
path in a better way like if i didn't
meet those two people
i wouldn't be an entrepreneur so that
would have been a huge loss for me
so as part of your advice perhaps then
uh maybe not so much university that's
fine uh
maybe it is but uh like network and
broaden
your network in so much that you're
experiencing
other people and other opportunities to
thus
then not be so myopic and perhaps what
is that
you know what you think is the destiny
career towards money and sort of
experience and have the courage and the
gumption to go check out other things so
that you could be
uh sort of spiritually uh and
emotionally
and professionally understanding other
things are in this planet for you
as opposed to sort of the you know the
thoroughbred at the racetrack that's in
their
their one lane yeah i think that so it's
a two-part answer i think one
you have a personal responsibility to
go out and discover yourself and i think
younger people are not as motivated by
money as
older people because we don't have as
much you know
you don't have as many responsibilities
you don't have kids you don't have
a mortgage money is not as important so
uh younger people don't make as many
decisions
about money but giving yourself
you know a broad range of experiences
and opening yourself up to opportunities
and and being receptive to them i think
you have a responsibility young person
to do that on top of that though i think
that that we could do better as a
society
to encourage some of these things to
encourage entrepreneurship
in schools that's one thing i focus on
but it's
close to my heart because i think
there's a lot of people who could be
great entrepreneurs who are stuck
on a path that they don't like and they
can't get off
yeah but you know i'm not just going to
blame the government it's not the
government's fault it's not
corporations fault it's also you right
like you look it's your life
you got to step up take some
responsibility it's our parents
you know teaching your kids that explore
what you want to do you don't have to be
an accountant just because i'm an
accountant you know um
so it's both sides it's society it's
it's government corporate but it's also
family and your own personal
accountability for your life
well uh there's a couple quotes i'll
read to you because i think you're
you're speaking my language here so
vincent van gogh of all people said once
your profession is not what brings home
your weekly paycheck
your profession is what you're put here
on earth to do with such passion
and such intensity that it becomes
spiritual in calling
and i think for me as i'm doing this
research for the book and
ultimately my experience as well both
directly vicariously and indirectly
as you said in the opening here there's
a lot of people that are driving to work
in that commute
angry and frustrated because they've not
been
able to separate the paycheck from
that intensity of what is their calling
and putting the effort
towards what really fuels them and it's
it's frankly disappointing because i
think that's the culpability i'm
speaking to of the disengagement
that's prevalent in many of our
organizations
yeah and i think you know organizations
would do well to look at their
their company their employees and see
you know underperformers it
doesn't mean that they can't perform
well at your company maybe they're just
in the wrong
role right and and for people who are
who hate their jobs like you either
complain about it or you fix it
yeah which camp you're going to be in
like i like to work with the people who
are going to fix it and and
that often means making tough hard
decisions
uh it doesn't have to mean the jumping
in and doing something full-time but
trying and experimenting and it's it's
looked down upon like if you're a young
person
and you jump around from job to job for
the first five years it's looked
down upon i know resume yeah
well really that's the best thing that
you should be doing because you gotta
find what you love
it's not the first job that you get and
you stick on that career path for 30
years because you're gonna
you're gonna hate your life you have to
bounce around
and so that that that spirit is not
supported
uh by you know corporations by families
by our society
but it's important for people to go
through to discover what is their
calling
yeah so um my math is right sort of
you're born in uh 80.
yes yeah yeah so so i'm a 71
so i'm an exer in the middle between the
boomers and you guys and the millennials
so i got to ask you this is it a
generational
issue uh is what a generational issue
this malaise inside of the organizations
where again it doesn't matter
what age you are the data suggests that
people are disengaged
and ironically it more so millennials
right now across the globe so
is it because boomers are
preventing that curiosity that bravery
from gen xers and millennials do you see
that not being an issue and it's just
look each of us have to determine what
our dna is and who we are in order to
fulfill
what's our destiny and that's what we're
not doing regardless of age
so i i would kind of combine it i think
i think there's
i think everybody has been has a calling
has a purpose
has something that they would be great
at
you know michael jordan is great at
basketball if he was doing
you know investment banking he would be
great and it's it would came to the
world
to not have michael jordan playing
basketball right if he didn't find i
don't know how he picked up that first
ball
but if that didn't happen you know the
world would be a worse place because of
it
so i think we all have something great
inside of us you gotta channel it and
find out what it is
i think the generational thing
is interesting because we
younger people have more role models to
look at
to see people who have busted through
and become successful
it's never been easier to change to
start your own business
you don't need a million dollars to
launch a company you just need a website
you know we have all these young people
doing great things becoming big
entrepreneurs at a pace
that that we haven't seen before and so
younger people
have more role models to look up to have
more
possibilities to think about where the
older generation may have been more
schooled towards okay you go get your
job yeah
you know life may suck but we deal with
it and they don't think about changing
where the younger people we see we see
mark zuckerberg and all these young
entrepreneurs taking off and feel like i
want that man i want that with my life
why am i stuck doing this crap
so i think we've always i think it's
just human nature i think it's been
around forever just
younger people now we may have more role
models to look at people who've had that
success and we feel like
i want that for me yeah exactly
okay so another quote then um
plato so we'll go
real philosophical on you right now
plato said human behavior flows from
three main sources
desire emotion and knowledge
so if you were to think about the
career down here desire emotional
knowledge okay
so if you want to think about the
tenants of
that uh that employee that entrepreneur
and if if if plato is saying look our
behavior really is stemming from the
fact that you must have desire
uh in order to fulfill that life of
purpose let's say you must have the
emotion so you've got to be jacked to
actually want to do it
and you should have the intellect and
the knowledge expertise in which to
fulfill
how do you see those three things that
plato was pontificating about in terms
of
one's purpose and behavior
is it relevant today yeah so my approach
my coach is a little bit different i
think everybody has has
one word that helps define them so for
me it's belief
but i think everybody has their own word
and it's it's not
um it's not a profession right and my
word isn't
you know accountant or lawyer or
whatever but it's it's a value
something that we value more than other
things
in our life and i think this has been a
constant it's a constant across your
entire life and so if you think about
the movies you like to watch
the books you like to read the friends
you hang out with the songs you like
they're all tied together by a
consistent theme there's one word that
defines
your whole life and when you find that
it
makes it easier for you to go make
important life decisions
and where people often get a disconnect
is if they're working at a company
and their word is drastically different
than what the company's one word is
then you're unhappy
there's a there's a philosophical
fundamental
disagreement like you feel nauseous
working there because
but it's so if you're if you're if your
work was uh different
you know i like things that are
different i have to be different
everything i do is different you know my
house is different
i like different movies i'm a little off
the wall different and then you're
working at a bank
whose word isn't even close to being
different you're going to be unhappy
even if you're doing
you know you're a computer programmer
and you love computer programming and
you're doing computer programming at the
bank
you're not going to be happy because
your main value is not aligned with the
bank
you got to find out what your one word
is and it's not going to be
it may not be the exact same one word
but
it has to be at least a sister word and
some companies
this is a challenge for companies do a
better job explaining
what your one word value is because most
values you look at
the mission statements and the values
that companies come up with they're crap
nobody remembers any of them you try to
get the companies to remember
what their 10 values are you've got the
employees nobody's going to be able to
tell you what it is
some companies do a good job you look at
3m 3m is innovation
that's their one word you know if you
want to work at 3m you're going to love
innovation and if you are
if you love innovation you do great at
3m if you don't like innovation
if you're an innovative thinker you're
not going to last long you're going to
hate your job even if you're doing the
right tasks that you like doing
so companies need to do a better job of
cutting through the craft and their
boring bs mission statements and values
that don't mean anything to anybody and
come up with one word that helps to find
them because that makes it easier
for your your team to be able to come on
and say hey i'm totally aligned i'd love
this
i believe in it too i'm here with you
innovation believe
whatever it is it makes it so much
easier
well on that i'll leave you with my
personal adage and my one word
so my adage is this what i've lived by
since i probably turned around 18.
we're not here to see through each other
we're here to see each other through
and my one word that encapsulates that
is reciprocity
nice so what i offer to you is in this
exchange for
great intelligence and your feedback on
what should be or the definitions of job
career and purpose
is what i can do for you to help you
whenever you see fit to
allow me to pay it forward i.e
reciprocity
cool yeah i appreciate it i appreciate
it hey i got a question from one of the
youtube viewers what do you think about
the ten thousand
ten thousand hours to be excellent at
something i watched a ted talk which
said you only need 20 hours
yeah i i although malcolm is uh
canadian like uh you and i i uh i call
bs on that as well
you know what um we've seen people pick
up the violin because it was an innate
skill and all of a sudden they become
a magician we've seen people who didn't
know that they could write haiku poetry
and next you know they're pumping out
haiku poetry like it's nobody's business
sure i think if you want to excel
extremely well at
something yeah i think practice makes
perfect the old adage
but just because you might not be a good
gardener
doesn't mean that you can't practice it
and i don't think it necessarily means
you need 10
000 hours to be a better gardener i just
you know that was marketing for me yeah
well that came that question came from
chefs tv so thank you chefs uh my quick
view is
you know it really depends if you're
passionate about it too if you love
something you'll learn it you'll pick it
up a lot faster
than if you're just trying to plow
through something that you don't hate
it's going to take you a lot longer
precisely anyway dan when does the book
come out
uh looks like the spring of 24 no 2015
um yeah so we're really looking forward
to it
cool well i've got to hop another call
but uh thank you so much for the time
appreciate it
and uh keep me posted with the progress
hey thanks man i do appreciate it all
the best believe buddy believe
yeah man reciprocity cheers